(crowd shouting loudly)
- Keep moving!
- [Crowd] Let's go!
(drum beats rhythmically)
Let's go!
- Keep moving!
- Let's go!
(indistinct chatter)
(crowd chanting loudly)
(drum beats rhythmically)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a lawyer turned,
cancel culture survivor,
turned candidate for Senate
from the great
state of Missouri.
Mark McCloskey, welcome
to the Rubin Report.
- Hey, thanks for having me on.
- I'm thrilled, truly
thrilled to have you on,
because what you
are doing right now,
by getting into the
game after the monster
tried to destroy you
I think is exactly
what America needs.
So, I'm putting my cards on
the table and just saying
that at the top,
as an interviewer,
everyone knows the video,
everyone knows the video.
We played it already at the
beginning of you and your wife.
When the Black Lives Matter,
anti-activists were outside
of your house and you have
decided to run for Senate.
So, before we do anything else,
let's throw to the commercial.
- When the angry mob came
to destroy my house
and kill my family.
I took a stand against them.
Now, I'm asking
for the privilege
to take that stand
for all of us.
I will never back down.
(dramatic music)
Our nation is under attack.
Big Tech, big business.
The swamp in DC are all
working together to destroy
our God-given freedom, our
culture and our heritage.
When was the last time a
politician defended you,
defended America, stood
between you and the mob.
We need defenders but
all we get is dividers.
Every day, they teach
us to hate each other,
left versus right, black
versus white, rich versus poor.
This is a tactic to destroy
us, but we are all Americans.
We are Missourians
our nation, our state,
our homes are worth defending.
Our freedoms are
worth defending.
I can promise you one thing
that when the mob comes
to destroy our homes,
our state and our country,
I will defend them.
I will never back down.
- All right, Mark.
Why, why would you get back
into the fight after going
through what you went through?
- Well, you know, what most
people don't understand
or don't remember, because
the press didn't report it,
because it wasn't good
for their narrative.
Was that, after the first
assault on the 28th of June
the mob came back on July the
third with a specific intent
of killing us and
burning down the house.
And it was now twice as many
people as it was on the 28th
and we had six Navy seals and
10 secondary employment police
and the FBI light aircraft
circling the house
and we had a standoff
against a thousand people.
And that was the night
that the president
gave his Mount Rushmore
address and he talked about,
defending against Marxist
extremism in the United States.
Well, I didn't get to hear
that speech that night.
I was a little busy
saving my behind
but I listened to
it the next day.
And the media
reported that as being
the most divisive speech
a president could give.
And I said to myself
and I said to my wife,
when this country is
in such a condition,
where the media reports
defending against
Marxist extremism
as being divisive, like we're
supposed to live together
in harmony with the people
that seek to destroy us
and our way of life
and our culture,
we've gotta do
something about it.
So, we just decided to
put our lives on hold
and do everything we could
to defend this country,
support the president
and so we went on
the campaign trail
and then when we're
on the campaign trail,
two things, one is
every place we spoke,
we found that people
were just sick and tired
of what's going
on in the country,
cancel culture, the poison
of critical race theory,
the lie of systemic racism,
all backed up with a
threat of mob violence.
People wanted genuine
change and you know,
we had genuine change
with Donald Trump
and if the election had
officially gone the way
that we had expected, then
we'd had done our task
but we'd had gone back to
being just ordinary citizens
but it didn't turn out that way
and we continue to
campaign on our own,
after the election, continue
to give rallies and support
of our constitutional rights
and our God-given freedoms.
And we found out
the second thing
and that is that everybody
that we ran into at every rally
there'd be somebody that
would tell us a tale
of a personal miracle
where God had made
a personal intervention
in their lives
and had made a
material difference
and hope there a miracle
happened and we realized
that this was something that
we were obligated to do,
that we had to give back.
We found that we just decided
that we had to do something
to save this country, no
matter what we could do
personally we had to do it,
because this country
is so close to the end.
I said, throughout the campaign
that this was our
last opportunity to
save our democracy.
That if we didn't,
re-elect Donald Trump,
the left would pack
the Supreme Court,
nationalize elections, go
for a DC and Puerto Rico
statehood, eliminate
the second amendment
with just Judicial fiat,
everything that has come true
in the last four months.
And we used to talk about the
erosion of civil liberties,
but now there's just
a wholesale slaughter
of our civil liberties.
And we also now have a state
of what can only be described
as socialism where the
government is now paying people
more to stay home and
live off the government
then they go out and work.
When I'm driving around
Missouri these days
and we do it all
of the time now,
every mom-and-pop shop,
every gas station,
every convenience
store has a sign out
saying hiring all positions-
- Same here, same here.
- Can't find employees because
employees can make more money
by sitting on their dock
on the false promise
of something free
from the government,
but the government never
gives you anything free,
what the government does is
takes your freedom in exchange
for a false promise of a better
life without having to work.
And you know, that bill
eventually comes due
and no matter what this
current administration says,
you're gonna have to pay
the bills (inaudible).
- Yeah, well, eventually they
either gotta pay the creditors
or go to war with them,
which at this rate
who the hell knows, I
don't wanna dwell too much
on the original events, but if
you could just talk about it
from really from a
personal perspective,
you live on a private street
that was gated and locked.
They broke in, now you're
trying to protect your house
and you know, once we
see these things on TV
it almost becomes,
because of the reality
nature of everything,
It's almost like a cartoon
when people are watching
it, you don't really realize
that these are real
people in their home,
that they own, their property.
As you said, defending
their property
with their God-given
right of owning arms.
Can you just talk a little
bit about what it was like
that moment when you
had to say to your wife,
I assume, you know,
we gotta get the guns,
we're literally
threatened right now?
- Well, and it takes a
little bit of background too,
because 28 days earlier,
on June the first,
night of June the
first, June the second,
in response to the
George Floyd event,
the people that always
are preaching their
moral superiority
to us decided there a
way to establish peace
and love was to burn
down Downtown St. Louis
and they rioted and they looted,
that night, four police
officers were shot,
Police captain, David
Dorn was murdered
during secondary employment,
about a half a mile
from where I'm
sitting right here.
- Wow.
- In the ensuing three weeks,
more and more businesses
got looted and boarded up,
a little pharmacy around
the corner from my office
which is just three blocks
from here was broken into,
they pried up the
steel rolled on doors,
stole everything
they could steal,
broke everything
they couldn't steal.
So, I asked the
owner, I said, "Well,
"did the cops ever show up?"
10 hours after the
alarm went off.
My wife and I watched the
711 in Downtown St. Louis,
two blocks from the
police headquarters.
From the time the first
brick went through a window,
people came in, looted it
empty, through in fire,
building becomes
engulfed in flames.
Patty and I are watching
it from our bedroom
on a live telecopter feed,
10, 20, 30, 40 minutes.
No police showed up,
no fire showed up.
We looked at each other
and said, you know,
when the fit hits the shan,
you're out there on
your wild lonesome.
And so, that's the context,
when we see this mob coming down
the street, three to 500 of 'em,
six lane road completely
filled from side to side
for as far as we can see
and then all of a sudden,
the gate bursts open, right,
and they start storming in.
Now, these are the same people
that had just burned down
in town and killed people
and destroyed millions of
dollars worth of stuff.
And you know, The Liberal
press would have me interrogate
each one as they came
through the gate,
now are you in the
good (inaudible)
or are you the bad-
- Right, right, right.
Are you the peaceful protester?
- Yeah, and by the
way, what's your race?
Let me see your
birth certificate.
All this kinda BS.
No, they broke down the gate
and they started storming in,
the first thing I did was
say, the two most racist
white superiority comments,
you'd say in the world
I said, "Private property."
And of course these people
were being communists.
When I said private
property that inflamed 'em
and they just came rushing in.
Well, my wife went
in to call 911.
My daughter was with us
that night too, she's 31.
She'd come in from
Chicago for dinner.
She went in to call 911.
I went around the
first door I could find
and grab my AR
which I had staged,
because we'd heard
they might be a riot.
And went out on the porch
and I started saying,
"Private property, get out."
I probably said
something impolite,
like get the hell out
of my neighborhood.
And then all of a sudden,
thinking that Patty's still
in the house calling 911,
all of the sudden she shows
up in front of me on the lawn,
waiving that dumbass Bryco
pistol over her head, right
and she never fired
a gun in her life,
but now I've got a problem,
because I don't have
a clean line of fire,
she's between me and the mob
and if something bad happens,
I can't put off a shot,
because I might hit her.
I kinda like her, you know,
I wouldn't wanna
have to accidentally
put a bullet in her.
And so now I've gotta
come out in the front lawn
and that's the scene
that everybody sees
and that 32 second clip,
that's on all the news,
that's the last 32 seconds
after the entire crowd
has already dissipated but
there were people in front of me
wearing body armor,
carrying weapons.
One guy pulls two loaded
magazines out of the pockets
of his body armor,
points them at me,
so I can see they're
loaded with rounds.
- Wow.
- Clicks them together
and says, "You're next."
This guy standing next to
him, also with body armor,
got a sidearm on
and he keeps inching closer
and closer and closer.
I mean, these were not
peaceful protestors.
These were people that were
there, meaning business.
And afterwards...
Go ahead.
- Did you feel, yeah,
well did you feel in some
way that your whole life
had led up to that
in an odd sense?
I mean, obviously you didn't
know that you were gonna run
for Senate just a
couple of months later,
but you were prepared
for this moment.
- They knocked on
the wrong door, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I had been a
very vocal anti-communist
my whole life.
I had been speaking and
interestingly (inaudible)
and we did a video
with him last week
but back and I was
reminiscing with him,
because we've known
each other for 30 years,
but back when I was in
college, I was lecturing
against the Sandinistas in
Nicaragua and Daniel Ortega.
and here it is, all
these years later
the Sandinistas are still
in charge of Nicaragua.
Daniel Ortega is still there,
but now John Kerry is
sort of complaining
about (indistinct) North
doing business with Iranians,
now John Kerry's doing
business with the Iranians.
You know, what a world.
- Yeah, something didn't
go right in the course
of those three decades or so.
One more question on
the original incident
and then I really do wanna talk
about what you wanna
do going forward.
Can you just talk?
'Cause I know so many
people are just so afraid
of the mob and I mean that
literally and figuratively
can you just talk about what
it was like to see your name
in the media being called
a white supremacist
and just all the awful stuff
that you had to deal with
and then we'll move on to
sort of what you're gonna do
going forward?
- Well, the good news is,
well, I said this to
the very first reporter,
if I had been the senior partner
at the largest law
firm in St. Louis,
I would've had to apologize
until I was blue in the face
and then resign my job anyway,
the only reason I was allowed
to go forward with my life
was that we're self-employed,
we're independent
and nothing the press could
say was gonna bother me
one way or the other
and I think the second interview
I had was with Chris Cuomo
and my wife advised me not
to go on the Cuomo Show.
You know, I knew what I
was thinking (inaudible)
but the very first
thing he says is,
"How do you like being the
face of white resistance?"
Right and what a load
of horse manure, right?
I had no idea what race people
are when they're coming in.
I saw an angry mob.
They're coming down the
street and you know,
you've gotta understand that
this was not a benign event.
You've got people screaming
at the top of their lungs,
chanting, beating on
drums, hammering the street
with sticks, and
then they burst in
and you know that they've
just killed people,
you know that they've
burned businesses down,
they've ransacked and now
they're right in front of you.
And I mean, we're talking 40,
50 feet in front of the house
and coming towards you,
this is not a benign event.
And I had no expectation
of surviving.
If I tried to defend myself,
I had no expectation that
surviving if I didn't,
but by God I wasn't gonna
go down without a fight
but we held them off.
No one got hurt, not
a shot got fired.
You know, right now there
are people I think more
than 36 of them sitting in
solitary confinement cells
for the offensive trespass
on the U.S. Capitol,
none of the three to 500
people that trespassed
in my yard saw day in jail,
let alone months of
solitary confinement.
So, it really is a different
way than the system works
if you're a Republican
or if you're a Democrat.
- Yeah, all right,
so with that in mind,
you are running as a Republican,
as you said, you've
been a conservative.
What would you say are
like the main factors
in how you view
your political life?
- Well, the major thing is
we just need to re-establish
who runs this country?
The Declaration of Independence
was pretty (inaudible)
and concise, you know, that
we have rights endowed by God
including life, liberty,
and pursuit of happiness.
And I always start my
speeches with a recitation
of the Declaration
of Independence
but I always stop with
a line in amongst these
are life, liberty and
the pursuit of happiness.
Then Joe Biden made a
speech the other day
and in his speech, he said this,
he started talking
about the constitution.
You know, Joe has a hard
time getting sentences out
but eventually he says, "We
the people are the government."
Not the people.
He said, "We the people
are the government."
And I popped up on my computer
the actual written transcript
of his speech and that's
actually what he said.
And so since then,
I've been adding
the next line to my speech
and that is, that to
secure these rights,
governments are
instituted among men,
deriving their just powers from
the consent of the governed
and that's what my
campaign is all about,
to remind those folks up in DC
that the government exists by
the consent of the governed
and they've ignored that,
they think we exist subject
to whatever
privileges they think
that they will
dribble down to us,
whatever they think we deserve
but the power
resides in the people
and we need to pull it back.
- What do you think the main
issues are for the people
of Missouri right now?
I mean, I understand sort
of the broad freedom aspect
and the federal governments,
you know, encroaching
and all this stuff, but
are there sort of granular
on the on the ground
issues in Missouri
that you think are
unique to that state?
- Well, yeah, you know
of course taxation is an
issue, of course spending
and creating fiat money that
just weakens the economy
and devalues everything,
Gas prices, I mean we're
an agricultural state
and imagine how much more
expensive it's going to be
to plant and harvest this year
by 50% in the last four
months and the border crisis.
I mean, once again, being
an agricultural state,
when you've got
hundreds of thousands
or eventually millions of
illegal aliens pouring in,
what's that do for
the economy of states
that would otherwise employ
American citizens to do
that same labor,
it is devastating.
And once again, it's two
things, it's devastating
to the economy and it dilutes
the legitimate voter rolls
of everywhere, including
your state in California
and mine here in Missouri.
And that's done intentionally,
I mean there's no accident
involved in any of these
things and then fair trade.
I mean, once again,
we've spent decades,
my entire life until Donald
Trump got elected president,
letting the rest of the
world take advantage of us
and trade and now
we're right back there
and can you believe, can
anybody in this planet believe
that Joe Biden is
allowing the Russians
to build their pipeline while-
- Incredible.
- The XL pipeline
in the United States.
What massive hypocrisy,
who does this guy work for?
- Who did, well it ain't
him making the decisions.
I think that's clear, has Trump
or anyone from the Trump
campaign reached out to you?
Because in some ways it's like,
man he should be just out
there with you tomorrow.
- Well the, and no, you know,
obviously we would love to have
the president's endorsement
but we've had no contact
with him directly.
I sure would like
to because you know,
he did more in four
years despite being
blasted by the media
every single day
and having nothing
but negative reporting on him
and you know, every
time he blew his nose,
there was a reason
to impeach him
and yet he did
more in four years
than anybody else had
done in the last 40
and now to see it
all wiped away,
all that progress
destroyed by, you know,
who's running the country?
I don't know.
It certainly isn't Mister,
I'm gonna hide in my basement
so I don't have to tell
anybody what I believe in.
- How's the coverage been for
you, the mainstream coverage
in Missouri and nationally?
You know, the
second I saw the ad,
I said to my guys,
get him on now.
And you guys, you know
that's when I know
it's a real campaign
because your people
immediately responded
unlike what's going on here
in California where
Caitlyn Jenner's people,
completely MIA.
So, to me, that's just theater,
your people (clicks fingers)
working on it and here you are
but how's the mainstream
coverage been for you?
- Well, I'll answer
that first part first.
I mean, how, why
am I here today?
Is I got a text message from a
grassroots supporter of mine,
saying, "Hey, Dave Rubin said,
"that if you wanna
be on his show,
"he's got an open invitation."
So, I contacted by my
campaign manager and said,
"Get me on Dave
Rubin's Show today."
- I think we had traded
there, we had emailed
just as your guys had emailed
us, something like that.
Yeah, fantastic, I mean,
that's what it's all about,
that's a beautiful thing.
- So, we've got two
major papers in Missouri.
We've got well,
in the big cities,
we got two big cities,
we've got Kansas city
and we've got St. Louis.
St. Louis Post-Dispatch
and The Kansas City Star
and if I were a Adolf
Hitler or Joseph Stalin,
I'd have gotten more
favorable coverage, okay.
And the National Press-
- What are they saying?
What are they saying,
just the same old stuff?
- Just the gun waving
St. Louis couple
whose only qualification
for political office
is that they pointed guns
at peaceful protesters.
I mean, that's uniform lying.
I was interviewed by an
AP reporter this morning
and he had written
that same big lie
in his article two days ago.
So, I brought for him
today a photograph
of the BLM protestors
stepping over the gate
that they had smashed
down, despite the fact
that the fake news mainstream
media constantly reports
that they were walking
peacefully through an open gate.
And you know, that mainstream
media has little interest
in, little or no
interest in actual truth.
They have an agenda
but we know that
and that's not gonna bother us.
- Yeah and I can sense
already a ground swell
of online support for you,
which is obviously fantastic.
I guess we can wrap with this,
which is, what would you want
anyone else watching this
to know about standing
up for yourself
and why you gotta do it?
'Cause not only did you
do it, you then decided
to double down and go
into the flames again
and no matter what happens here,
I think it's an
incredible story.
- Well, here's what I've
been saying to everybody
and I'll say it until I die now
or until the country goes first
and that is, you can no longer
depend on the government.
You can't hope that Big Tech
or big business
is gonna save you.
If you don't like critical
race theory, get involved,
elect a school board
that will prohibit it.
If you don't like
unconstitutional
mandates coming down
from your mayor or your county
executive, vote 'em out.
Put in real conservatives
that'll respect
the citizens rights.
If you don't like what's going
on in your state Capitol,
throw out the RINOs,
throw out the Democrats,
vote in a real conservative.
Every single citizen needs
to make a personal commitment
to taking back their freedoms,
vote in people that you
can trust and vote out,
if they don't live
up to your trust.
And you know, if
people wanna help out
if people think we've
got a right idea,
go to mccloskeyforsenate.com,
donate whatever you can.
Five, 10 bucks, it's a
real grassroots campaign.
You know, the media
is gonna dump on us,
the left's gonna come down
on us like a ton of bricks.
I suspect maybe even some
of my Republican cohorts
will have less and complimentary
things to say about us
but I don't care.
We're here to represent
the people of Missouri
and if the people of Missouri
want to have somebody
who not subject to intimidation,
who has no strings attached,
who will do everything I can
and will never back down.
And when I go to rallies,
I get a general outpouring
of similar belief.
Everybody knows that our rights,
our freedoms are
given to us by God,
that when the founders
of this country
wrote the Declaration
of Independence
and the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights,
they weren't creating
privileges for us,
They were merely
recording in paper,
the rights we're born
with as human beings,
made in the image
of God (inaudible).
- Mark, well said, man, I
wish you the best of luck.
I'm so impressed by the story
and this is exactly
what America needs.
We're gonna link down to
your Senate campaign below.
So, hopefully people
will jump over there,
throw you a couple
of bucks if they can.
And I wish you luck and
I hope we cross paths.
And maybe if I make
it out to Missouri
I'd love to join you on stage.
I'll get the crowd going for ya.
- Alrighty, I'd
sure appreciate it.
- Awesome, thank you so much.
- Take care.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.